欢迎收听古爱,我是孙孟公
本期节目由尼古清赞助
戒烟如同投资,需要放弃短线刺激与快感
以追求长期健康复利
过去我很常抽烟,一天两包聚会工作
休息时间一根接一根
直到后来为了自己与家人的健康才下定决心要戒烟
当初我主要是靠戒烟贴片成功戒掉烟饮
身为过来人,我蛮鼓励大家可以尝试戒烟辅助品
今年8月,尼古清戒烟口含定即将上市
使用简单零门槛
像薄荷定一样放入口中
即可快速缓解烟影
薄荷口感清新口气
戒烟新手也容易接受
适合上班会议时使用
让偏好低调的戒烟族
也能够随时随地的快速缓解
另外尼古清戒烟喷雾是品牌独家技型
一喷利己缓解
适合在社交通勤
需要快速缓解不适的戒烟族群
尼古清帮助戒除止烟
电子烟以及加热烟
让你不被烟影打扰
专注生活每一刻
只靠个人意志力
戒烟成功率通常低于5%
过程中最难的
并非下定决心要开始戒除
而是每次烟瘾来袭的瞬间
如何撑过阶段症状
以及吸烟的冲动
尼古琴让戒烟不只是硬撑
而是帮助戒烟者
在重要时刻缓解当下的烟瘾
一步步拿回生活中每一刻的主导权
加战家屋股份有限公司
台北市中央区民生东路三段
二号石楼尼古琴戒烟口
寒定二豪克
胃部药书自帝029-054号
尼古清街言澎湖衛部要書字第027835號
北市衛要廣字第115060214號
明天對我來講是一個非常重要的日子
它就是紅顏露比的登場日
非常希望大家都可以
我相信絕大多數的聽眾在我們的呼籲之下
一定把它放進去Wishlist裡面
如果說你還沒有的話
希望你可以去試玩看看這一款遊戲
你在Steam是可以找到試玩的
或是說如果後面評價是蠻不錯的
你想要試看看
想要挑戰看看
歡迎都去把這一款遊戲找來玩
它是由台灣非常優秀的遊戲開發團隊
杯狗遊戲他們所參與開發
以及校南資本非常幸運
可以去參與投資這樣子的一個優秀的團隊
其實我們後續還是有一些遊戲會持續的登場
像是下一款暗華夜展
預計在明後年會上
這一款大家在Steam上面
也是已經可以找到它的試玩
換一邊都去玩看看
同時我們也有一些遊戲
是已經在市場上面在跑了
但是因為我們跟每個團隊
可能簽的deal是不一樣
所以有些我們不會公布
但只能夠說這個算是我自己非常美好的一兩年
自己喜歡且覺得很讚很棒的團隊
都可以把它收進來去參與他們的成長
作為一個evergreen fund
我們不會去要求我們的funder或是我們的團隊
他們必須要交給我們怎麼樣的ROI或怎麼樣
我們就希望說我們給他們所需要的資源我們也看準這些團隊當然也不是說什麼隨便亂花錢隨便找團隊亂丟我們也知道說他們有潛力一個願打一個願挨然後一起去做出一款可能非常棒的遊戲
然後一起把台灣的遊戲
帶到了一個新的高度
那這可能也是我自己在接下來
會比較想要去著重
跟努力的一個方向
那也非常感謝有像古愛這樣子的一個節目
那可以讓我去把這些事情給分享出來
因為如果你自己在那邊做的話
老實講
力氣就是沒有這麼大
那當然今天有一個節目
有一些聽眾有一些支持跟相信你人
大家一起在上面去做參與
一起去推崗的話
其實我們的力量是會大非常的多
所以非常感謝大家的支持
希望歡迎Ruby可以開出非常好的成績
也希望我們的下一款暗花夜戰
以及我們已經在上市中的遊戲
可以持續的在全球市場裡面
去造成那種現象級的反應
就是真的很多事情是超出我們想像的
我們沒有想到說
我們喜歡的這些團隊
他們的作品
我們當時就是覺得超棒的
可是他們竟然可以紅到國外去
或什麼
這個是想都不敢想的東西
我們希望在紅蓮露比
也可以看到這樣子一個情形
我們希望可以看到
可能海外的一些實況主跟直播主
會想要開箱這個作品
然後玩給大家看
那抑或是我們也可以辦一些抽獎
我們可以去提供給我們的
忠實聽眾CDKey之類
這個對我來講都是小事情
如果可以讓更多人來參與
其實是不錯
因為我覺得說
像最近的盤面比較辛苦一點
我自己有在想
就是可能多抽一點CDKey
或是我可能把家裡的一些酷東西
拿出來抽給大家
就讓大家知道說
在市場回檔的時候你不孤單
其實老實講你要講絕對數字
我一定也是賠很多錢
因為大家在回檔都是不會好受的
你一個人苦
但是想到有別人跟你一起苦
可能就沒有這麼痛苦對不對
一個人苦會覺得好難受
可是其實在這樣的一個
市場比較震盪的一個過程之中
還是要去注意好自己的身體健康
千萬不要說什麼炒股票炒到
整個人變得面目可正
然後或者說講話是充滿那種暴力之氣
這個就是一個不好的現象
像最近也有跟一個我們林口富爸
就是我們一個地方的好朋友聊天的時候
也有講到這件事情
其實我們最後面在做的事情
都是希望股票不要去影響到生活
這個不要影響到生活其實是很多層面的
大家都以為說影響到生活
一定是你可能賠錢的時候
不一定
有可能是你今天是很賺錢的時候
然後你每天都只想要去搞更多
那就可能不知道
家人可能要帶你出去
你說不要我只要搞股票
我只要坐在盤前面
你明天到峇里島了
不要游泳
我只想在那邊炒股
那亦或是說在回黨的時候
可能就開始去想要去call家人之類的
這個不要去了
那個我們之後再說什麼的但其實你知道你的震盪早就已經可以完全的cover這些東西了所以應該就是一人做事一人當你知道說反正我們身為父親絕大多數我們身邊仇宅
也是爸爸為主
但也有一些地方人妻也是非常厲害
只是我們這些地方爸爸陣線
就是知道說
那壓力就是我們自己擔在身上
當今天可能不好受的時候
像我就會找兒子來跟他開個玩笑
說這邊都是綠的時候
你要給爸爸一點空間
爸爸需要思考
他現在早上就會問我說
爸爸今天是紅色還是綠色
就蠻有趣的
但也不希望給他太多這樣子一個認知
讓他覺得好像是
今天假設盤面不好就不要去惹他爸
沒有就是讓他知道說
他爸爸到底在做什麼東西
同時讓他稍微的了解一下
一切都是得來不易
可是同時我們不希望讓他感受到壓力
好像說就像我剛剛前面講到的
你一個人在那邊搞股票
然後搞到全家跟著你一起
氣氛變得很差
或是說什麼你要跑到網上去發洩
像最近蠻多就是
回去抓一些地方老闆來罵
這個我覺得也超怪的
因為老實講這一波回檔
你看一下韓股 你看一下美股
其實科技股很多都跌很深
三四成以上那個叫基本
就是一大堆都跌這樣
所以你專門去找幾個老闆來罵
甚至有些人發出那種生命威脅
你就要注意你一時的嘴秋
你可能就會導致
你後面有一些官司要吃
那在嚴格上來說
或說退一萬步來說
你知道這些東西它year to date都非常多
所以怎麼講
就是他絕大多數的股東其實是賺錢的
那你為什麼會搞到賠錢
甚至斷頭被掃出場
這個其實是要反省一下
自己的一些操作是不是有問題
其實我們在過往也是一直去做這樣的反省
然後後來才調整出自己適合的一些方法
像我又跟大家分享說
其實老實講我以前就超喜歡開那種超大的槓桿
只是後來就發現說每次在回檔或怎麼樣
搞到整個人蓬頭垢面壓力超大
這個可能不是你要的一個生活
所以就慢慢的去做一些調整
只是當然我過去跟大家講這個
我說以前我是玩命之徒
後來發現說
靠北媽槓桿2.5倍根本不叫玩命之徒
叫小資保險族
因為它新一代的股民
2.5倍叫做幼幼斑
沒有人只開2.5倍
大落開超大
可能像這一波的回檔
一定就是蠻多就遭受到了巨大的打擊
其實你去看那種古旗盤前的變化
莫名其他自己撞去跌停就知道
就有人又要跳樓又要斷頭了
再來就是有一些那種追腳令發出去
所以我曾經說這個都是一種經驗
就是你有發生過的人
你下次就會知道我不能這樣子
可是如果說你沒有發生過
人家跟你講一萬次你也聽不懂
就像說在我們節目每次最樂觀的時候
大家去回測一下
從2020年到現在都是
每次只要在多頭的高峰的時候
全部人都在問我正二
全部人都在問我說怎麼樣槓桿
怎麼借更多錢然後再來就是像這波也很準前面一個兄弟問我說全資投資問完直接爆炸所以你看我們全資投資的指標還是很準每次真的是那種就是大多頭然後開始有人在問全資投資的時候
你就知道就是差不多了
可是我們也沒有料到會突然間這麼快
所以其實這波算是殺得非常的快
而且很有趣的現象就像上集跟大家聊到
其實大盤是沒有什麼動
大盤跌不多
可是很多中小的跌要爛掉
你看台灣的貴買
或者說美國的一些那種小科技
其實蠻多摔得很重很重
所以就是一個 cautionary tale
我覺得其實不需要太擔心
因為嚴格上來說
這個我覺得它只是一個預言
因為後面一定會有更大的
大家真的只要摸住自己的軟蛋
跟自己的心臟
好好跟自己對話一下
後面那個更大的你扛不扛得住
我們講的並不是說什麼
在接下來立刻要發生一些更大的
我們是在講說
因為按照我們的經驗
循環就是長這樣
小循環掉小坑
大循環摔大坑
這波循環是大家都知道是
超出大家想像
AI太猛了
拉超級高
你看台子加4萬多點
下一個回檔一定是很慘
這個一定是非常慘的
所以大家要做好心理準備
就如果說像這樣的一些小壓力測試
就有辦法讓整個人爆掉
然後開始變成是一個怪人的話
那就要注意說如果真的來的時候
是有沒有辦法去扛住
希望大家都是有辦法
希望大家都是抱持著比較健康的心態
回歸到最原本
可能就先前投資
不要開太大的槓桿
注重家庭跟生活
有事每次打個紅顏路比
玩個暗花夜戰
玩一下硝南資本有參與的遊戲
當然硝南資本沒有參與的遊戲
大家還是要玩
希望大家多多支持
去找到生活的重心
這個非常重要
這真的非常重要
接下來我們來進入市場的話題
最近的兩天市場就開出了人道走廊
我們把它稱為人道走廊的主因
是因為它其實在一些主要的均線下面
當然像台股其實是有漲破季線
這個算蠻關鍵的
但是目前還是會把它視為
是一個比較警戒的階段
為什麼
因為當你反彈上來的時候
你就會碰到很多的均線
就可以想像成說前面有一些套牢的賣壓
就會在這個時候把它丟出來
所以最好的狀態是什麼
就是它彈起來之後洗一洗之後再繼續進攻
如果說你注意到自己手上的東西
彈起來之後它沒有辦法繼續進攻
或是它彈起來彈不太起來
然後接著又再繼續往下掉的話
有可能它就在下一波的族群裡面就會落對了
只是像它這個盤面
我覺得它很困難的一個點是
基本上市場上的一些主流股
過往很強大的主流族群
除了像載板今天是集體蠻多多漲田
那個算非常強勢之外
很多的股票你都注意到說
它形態已經有點像是說就跌壞掉了
即便是一些那種大家耳熟能詳的
大名子就像台灣的一些那種PowerRack超級大廠
那個反彈的力量也都沒有到很大
所以我就覺得說這些東西是有機會
會進入一個休息的階段
那要記得他們其實並不是說什麼基本面
不知道什麼
因為其實以下的角度是
我認為啦
在接下來一段時間是大家會看到很多業績
會開出來的時間點
就連像可能過去疊了比較深的被動元件
最近很多字節開出來
都是非常漂亮的年增
那只是當然可能他撐不住
就是在過去漲數倍這樣子的一個壓力
因為你漲多
那大家就會開始去檢查你的基本面
那可能就會校正回去
基本面該有的一個軌道之類的
但整體來說就是我們應該是可以
合理的去預期在後面的
蠻多公司的成績都其實會接連的開出來
特別是VR-Rubin開始要放量出貨
再來可能像AMD有一些事件要產生
因為他們要正式的去發表Venice
也就是它的SP7平台的CPU
在年底會有Auxstream
也就是Intel的下一代的
不管是Diamond Rapids
或者是Clearwater Forest
它的CPU也都要去丟出來
所以其實有蠻多東西會接連的放量
不管是從NVIDIA這邊的
大家比較熟知的GPU陣營
或是到AMD它是GPU跟CPU
大家都非常關注
大概是一個2比3左右的出貨量
他們所佔的一個產值
可以這樣子抓
再來可能一些ASIC
都是有機會在接下來要放量
包括我們知道說Trainium系列也是
所以其實這些公司
有接觸到他們的supply chain或什麼的
你都會知道它接下來的營收就是會好
它就是會好
只是我們沒有辦法確認會不會漲
因為其實蠻多型態是跌到不好看
我們是會去參考一些型態的人
就是像我自己的做法會有點像是hybrid
我會有一些架頭的東西
但架頭的東西不會是我的主軸
因為就算我今天有去架頭去蹲一些東西
但是我也會等到他可能今天有突破
他型態變好之後才去做更多的加碼
那不然說可能像一個東西
如果我今天覺得他是不是要開始出事情
說我也是這樣看
看月線撐不撐得住
季線撐不撐得住
撐不住那可能也是把東西給汰掉
所以即便我知道你的業績很好
可能在後面我一樣會用不一樣的態度去面對你
就知道你可能稍微的整理一下之後
像它這個盤面
我認為其實蠻多人的心態可能跟我差不多
特別是今天跟一些朋友
我們在差不多快收盤前的時候有一些交流
然後發現說怎麼大家選的東西都差不多
因為大家在市場上識別到強勢族群都差不多
像最近的話就是這些老AI重新的轉強
我覺得老AI轉強它有一個蠻明顯的邏輯
就是這些老AI其實在過去
他們算是休息了蠻長的一段時間
如果是在ODM這邊
你注意到蠻多的4PR
大概就落在10倍左右它就是一個10倍股啦就是便宜但是你不確定它上檔落有多少大家就還是會喜歡因為現在大家都想去找一些像我們跟大家提到的有業績有防守的東西
就大家心態
就那些聰明錢
基本上都是差不多的想法
因為開始知道說
這些高PER的東西被殺超兇
我當然就閃去可能比較安全的地方
但是我們可能也不安全會想要空手
像我自己是不會去做空手
我們自己身邊蠻多的朋友都是空手
所以其實我也不太確定說
如果這一波
它真的就不小心這樣
一路反彈衝出去的話
那這些人要怎麼樣追回來
可能就有點類似說前面有幾波是這樣
像今年的4月我覺得就算是
其實當盤可能掉到季線的地方的時候
你就注意到身邊超多人就不玩了
可是後來就直接開出去
開出去可能開出去三天五天
他們都還是忍得住
最後面就一樣就忍不住
就會衝進來追
所以還是有可能
因為像他真的有蠻多資金
我知道他們不玩了
還是有可能
就假設大盤就持續的轉牆的話
然後最後面還是有一堆人在後面要追
然後又再一次有動能盤的產生
但是直到我們真的可以去識別
這樣的一個機會產生之前
我自己還是會把它當成是一個區間盤去做操作
後來就發現說
其實有蠻多的大資都在做類似的事情
反正就是在下跌的時候
先把錢閃進去指數嘛
閃進去台積點嘛
然後等到大盤回穩之後
就開始從指數跟台積點拿錢出來
然後看去買東西
只是像今天我自己就會比較小心一點
你說昨天要去搶快
還可以理解
因為可能是第一根
可是到了今天你知道說
攤起來它會摸到一些大均線
我就在想說如果今天是坐不住
然後把錢全部尻出來去追的
就是有機會在後面
就會吃到一些一些的回答
假設盤沒死的話就是一些一些回答
假設盤真的就掛掉的話
那可能就是一個蠻大的回答
但目前我看我會覺得
還算是沒有到很悲觀的一個情形
就算大盤的形態不好
但現在確實只有買多東西
都直接跌到便宜的價格
這個價格可能是你在五六月是找不到的
就是買多東西是已經收斂回去
可能在我們的角度是
你拿來做長頭
或是你零鼓勵都不會輸的一個價位
只是關鍵是
當然這些東西便宜
可是便宜不代表有資金要去拉它
除非說你的心態就是來什麼純骨
零骨息之類的
來長頭的
那不然如果你的目的是希望有人要拉它的話
那你還是要注重一下心態
就是後面有沒有什麼一些
事件可以把它推上去
那心態不能夠太差
它如果覺得說
它已經掉到季線下面超級遠的
那個就是屬於心態比較不好的
就算它有一些基本面
很多時候像這樣的標的
我們會發現說
它會盤整個幾個月之類
它就沒有這麼快
那反正下有點像是說
就是大家各自帶開表現
那如果說你這個族群是有辦法拉出去
然後上面的共識也夠高的話
就有可能會吸引到
就是那些還是喜歡去做追高的人
就會往這個方向去
然後一些可能比較中型大型的資金我們自己有注意到說往那種業績股去跑的其實他們的線型也就是慢慢的在改善但是我自己會猜測這些業績股可能在噴的時候就不會這麼兇因為上面的資金就是不想要追高的才過來
他們都不想要追高
所以就會變成到底誰要去把這個價格推到更高
可能就是慢慢的去等每一次的營收
每一次的財報每一次的事件把它推上去
會變成往這樣的一個發展
所以後面就除非這個大盤從這邊開始就沿路噴
然後去拉新高
那可能就再次回到動能盤
但如果說沒有的話
那可能就會開始變成是比較累區間盤
然後再來就是中小
因為貴買指數真的是跌的
在我的角度是屬於比較不好看的啦
所以有機會
至少像身邊朋友最近在討論
就是大家都是想要去把錢從中小
然後可能移到一些比較大型的股票去
所以才會導致說很多人去往一些老AI
先跑到那邊去嘛
那知道這個地方可以防守
然後記得再去做調整
就跟類似說今天出一道盤掉下來
蠻多人就會閃進去台積電
跟閃進去台紙一樣
反正就會找一些這種相對便宜的東西
你知道說就算一樣要下去好了
我這東西可能下去是一層五到兩層
你那個高P的下去三層到五層之類的
那我當然先躲在這個地方
然後再看換去哪裡
所以市場的一些態度
我個人認為一下
是會長這樣的一個情形
在今天晚上
或者說明天跟後天
其實有蠻多事件會展開
首先大家都非常期待
Google的財報會怎麼樣開
財報這邊
我們是沒有瞇到什麼數字
或者說什麼特別的東西
就是在過去可能有時候會有一些東西
我們大概知道或市場有些猜測
但這一次我覺得
大家對於Google的財報預期
其實並沒有到很高
只要它不是開負面的消息
那應該就是用一個neutral的態度去看它
但是它昨天有一個新聞跑出來
就是他們有一個什麼Frozen V2的晶片
這個Frozen是我們都沒有看過的晶片
所以其實第一時間大家就去調查說它是什麼東西
有些人說它可能是Merobe
也就是TPU V10由博通設計的
可能對外的名字叫Frozen
可是有些人說它應該是Marvel的那一顆晶片
我們之前跟大家分享說Marvel有一顆叫做TIA晶片
其實這話有劍報
Information還是誰有把它寫出來
我們就有直接公布了
這顆晶片的全名就是TPU Inference Accelerator
就是一個你可以把它算成是TPU Family裡面的某一種可能在推論的加速晶片
它目前應該是沒有被編帶
就是它沒有像可能像HUMU跟ICE是V910
然後可能你去類推博通的話就是WELLFISH TriggerFISH
然後跟後面的MOROB
這可能是比較屬於那種正規軍
反正就是一個是訓練一個是推論
這個Frozen或是我們把它稱為TIA
我們現在認為是同一顆
當然如果有錯的話
歡迎大家來糾正我
這一顆應該就是由
Marvel去做設計的那一顆
就是專門去for inference加速使用可能是內部的某一些AI應用去做的晶片我們知道說Google其實還是有開一些有趣的晶片只是這些有趣的晶片不然說像昨天這個新聞出來蠻多人說可以去關注Google
我自己的想法是應該不是關注Google
因為這個對Google來講
就是一個可能自用的晶片
就算它後面會拿出來買
那個營收占比也是小到可以忽略
所以它比較不會是一個需要去關注Google的題材
而是你要去關注說誰做這顆晶片
可是這顆晶片
就是像我們自己的節目已經在
很久以前就已經跟大家拆完這些東西
所以你要知道
市場一堆人都知道
所以一堆人都知道的東西
有沒有辦法去造成一些催化
我就會去抱持一個問號
但還是得講
確實是有蠻多東西
一開始它是一個偏向消息面先拼先
然後後來就是用實質的營收
去做最後的決戰
最後面的儲存段
可能還是有實質的營收去帶出來的
所以有機會就是可能
雖然這個東西對我們來講是一個勞梗
但假設後面開始對一些公司
或是說相關的components有貢獻的話
說不定就會再一次的變成市場的某一種題材
所以以Google最近來講的話
因為它在模型方面又稍微的軟調一點
那一樣大家又開始去罵說Google沒有東西
還是得稍微提醒一下大家
反正說可能在AI時代
蠻多人的智力
或者說不要講智力不好聽
就是記憶
雖然這樣好像也不好聽
對就是變得很短
然後就喜歡到處去笑人家
然後前面笑Amphropic
然後笑OpenAI
然後現在笑Google
後面又要變成再去笑別人之類的
因為大家都是輪流的
不停的端出很屌的東西
然後去擊敗大家的預期
所以我覺得他可能就是在一個深蹲的階段
還是蠻相信說他整個目前
Ecosystem做起來是非常有機會的
所以就等看Google開什麼樣的成績
我們再跟大家聊
再來另外一個事件
AMD有一個Avancing AI 2026
他會在今天跟明天舊金山的
某一個地點去舉行
重點會是放在第二天
也就是麗莎樹的一個Keynote
大概是台北時間的凌晨12點半左右
我們就來看說他會不會再去做一些
針對AI的一些指引
先講一下可能市場有公佈
或說大家有預期大家知道的一個東西
我們可以expect有什麼樣的事情發生
首先是他們有先公告了
Microsoft這邊有大單
Ager會去部署大量的Helios機櫃
去跑他們的模型推論
再來除了Microsoft之外
我們知道過往Meta、OpenAI或是Oracle
他們有一個非常華麗的客戶名單
這個就是說現在多一個Microsoft進去畫龍點睛
後面還有一個比較大的驚喜
其實在法人圈或是投資圈裡面
或是投資圈裡面
已經不是驚喜了
可是我覺得應該有蠻多的消費者
不一定知道這件事情
就是Amphoropi這邊有機會
也會在這次的會議上面去公布說
跟AMD有什麼樣的一個合作
然後會去使用AMD
我們知道說AMD的伺服器在近期
其實它的狀況是表現得蠻好的
不只是它可能在GPU跟CPU這一段
可能在一些整合應用上面
大家也開始發現
有一個說法是這樣說
雖然可能講很久了
NVIDIA的CUDA的護城盒
其實慢慢的有在被降低中
因為大家在上面去
可能用AMD的比較高CP值的硬體
去開發一些軟體的應用
可能沒有像CUDA這麼順
可是至少是堪用的
所以也不是像過往大家講
因為AMD的東西就是相對便宜嘛
然後可以買到比較高的Spec
像他可能說因為自己有上去開發一些軟體
所以慢慢的有去導正這件事情
那市場有一個說法是說
等到它走到550這個階段之後呢
它會在硬體跟軟體的整個方面會跑NVIDIA
就看大家相不相信這樣一個論述
雖然我是覺得皮刀客它不是吃素的
它不會躺在那邊給你幹
那現在市場的一個論述說
因為跑到550那一代之後呢
它可能一個板子上面可以打
比NVIDIA還多顆的晶片
那NVIDIA相較之下
可能就只有在記憶體這邊有去做提升
所以搞不好硬體就有一個超車的機會
可是老黃可能突然間又在搞出某一種韌體
或是某一些特殊的軟體應用
又把它的performance又在整個推上去都是有機會
但至少就是說AMD這邊你可以去期待
它的GPU在後面是會有些表現的
然後有一些大型的客戶除了這些CSP之外
像模型商Amphlopic這個市場已經傳很久了
就是有機會也會被端出來說他們有去做合作
再來它的Keynote上面
我們覺得應該是會去正式發表Vanus
這應該也不是算是非常意外的事情
是非常意外的事情
Venice是什麼
就是它的SP7的一個CPU
這個CPU已經可以保證
基本上就是在後面
算是一個會供不應求的東西
首先我們知道說
AMD它在CPU的試占率是越拉越好
它基本上是有點像說
騎在Intel上面持續而去做攻擊
Intel當然它也只有端出新東西
只是它的AWKStream
就是它的下一代
不管是Clearwater Forest
然後或者是Diam Rapids
那應該是要等到今年年底
或是明年年初才會出來
所以AMD又可以搶先持點
然後看有沒有機會去攻佔下來
更多的一個試散
在這樣的一個時空背景之下
其實我們是認為說非常的有機會
只要它可以想辦法把CPU順利的出貨就好
CPU現在有一些瓶頸
除了在晶圓代工端這邊
可能要去secure更多的產能
which is very difficult
非常困難
因為大家都在搶這個產能
然後再來就是你要去拿到足量的記憶體
可能也是一個不容易的事情
你要把整個東西拼出來是不容易的事情其實我們今天如果挑到一個比較大的架構來看的話目前市場裡面很大的一個瓶頸其實是CPU如果說CPU沒有辦法順利的供應的話我們現在已經在很多的供應鏈上
已經有看到很多老闆在抱怨
甚至他們自己在做CPU相關components
他都告訴你說CPU很好
但是因為可能出貨這邊會卡住
所以我們的營收韌列進來
可能不會是那種一次性超大量的進來
會慢慢的
因為整個鏈是卡住的一個狀態
我們知道說CPU因為在Agenti AI的影響
它扮演一個非常重大的角色
從本來可能CPU是一個對
可能超多個七八個GPU ASIC
然後到現在1比4 1對2
甚至後面大家開始在講說
有可能有1對1的狀況產生
當時我們是講說這個可能講太早
但現在來看時間隨著這樣慢慢的推進
也是有機會看到這樣的一些情形出現
甚至是有一些像NVIDIA過往
它的CPU是直接打在板子上面
包著出的
說不定它後面會出一個Stand alone的版本
為什麼因為CPU的用量就真的變成很大
大家注意到在Agentic Wallflow裡面
其實會用到很多的CPU
所以我也覺得說Vanus它提早去誕生
它會為AMD帶來蠻大的一個優勢
特別是他們在上次好像是投資人大會
就是已經有把CPU的TAM整個蓋了一倍上去
就它給了一個非常高的數字
所以在Kindle上面
你可以去期待它怎麼樣去吹Vanus
雖然它的Spec大家都已經是相當程度的知道
也已經拿去跟Intel的Auxstream的Clearwater Forest
去做一個對標
但還是可以來看一下說
可能在上面去做更多的論述
不然說哪些客戶會採用
或是有一些什麼use case之類的
所以CPU相關的一些公司
也是在這一波
我會想要去關注的一個對象
除了CPU的本體
就像是Intel或是AMD
或是我們過往去
可能在美股注意的那些CPU的公司之外
然後再加上相關的components
我覺得也是有機會在
缺貨的一個狀況之下
可能大家都會產生更好的一個
一個議價權
就整條鏈有可能會
稍微的去做一個價值的提升
首先一個比較明顯的價值提升
是我們知道說
當每一次的CPU換代
上面的一些那種標準品
可能像是一些什麼被動元件
用量增加什麼
這個我們就不用講了
記憶體 不知道
這個就不用講了
如果今天我們是討論到
像CPU它負載的Sockets
因為它的對率大概就是1比1
除了像NVIDIA在它的AI伺服器裡面
不一定會用到一些Sockets
當然Socan這邊還是有用到
不過就是我們知道說
隨著CPU的換代
因為像Sockets它裡面的針角數就會變多
針角數變多的意思就代表說
它ASP會提高
因為它不像剛剛前面講到那些原件是
反正就是今天一個大潮來它就是跟著漲價大潮結束它就會崩掉像這樣子的可能一對一或是會綁定出的某一些零組件他會比較偏向是他在每一次的換代隨著像剛剛提到針腳變多
或是說技術難度變高
他會有一次ASP的提升機會
所以等到這個ASP拉上去之後
那有可能也會去改善公司的一些體質
所以整個CPU相關的supply chain
我會認為就是在AMD的keynote之後
有可能會再一次的被關注
第一波CPU可能是在今年年初的時候
那時候有炒一波
大家知道Intel跟AMD碰到爛掉
可能後面有機會
可能CPU會再帶動第二波
我自己是比較難去想像說
還有什麼樣的故事
因為你知道市場要繼續往上跑
就要有領頭羊
所以目前先觀察看看AMD有沒有機會
成為這樣子一個領頭羊
當然有可能Google搶先
假設Google開的數字突然間有一些
雖然我們很難去想像有超出預期的東西
但你覺得說它假設帶動市場的話
有可能就是它先跑
只是如果說Google這個東西沒有辦法帶起來
因為現在市場對它的預期其實不高
可能反而要期待AMD的Avancing AI
有沒有可能會端出什麼樣不一樣的東西
再來就是有一些可能對我們這些市場仔
或是投資圈人士法案圈
大家已經是就覺得是嘗試的東西
但是有可能傳到市場上
它還是會造成非常強大的一些催化
這個是有機會的
所以包含像是Anthropic
或者說它會不會再公佈
除了Anthropic之外的其他客戶
像那時候Broadcom
它去公佈客戶的時候
對我們來講
其實我們大概知道是誰
我們也知道說有這樣的訂單
但是那時候在市場上面
還是有造成一些影響
所以這些消息它都是有機會成為
某一種催化的一個催化劑
可能就後面再來觀察看看
總之就是在接下來
我覺得盤面是一個很震盪的情形
但是我們知道說
其實有蠻多公司的業績跟環境
都是在很好的一個狀態
然後再來就是可能像過去一集
跟大家聊到Keyme Carefree
很多人把它解讀成為說
可能美國的軟體定價會崩掉
這些模型定價會崩掉
然後再來就是
可能因為它是
大家把存款器比較有效率
雖然我們有去稍微打臉一下
因為它要用到的記憶體量
其實是超級大的
它是一個大型的東西
你不可以用什麼小型的桌機去跑
它跟那時候Deep Seek造成的想像
還是有一定程度的差距
但大家把它聯想在一起
絕對說不會用到這些伺服器
可是最後面我們看到KIMI
就是在我們上集聊完之後
他們就是有公布
直接告訴大家
月之愛命就跟大家講說
抱歉我們現在算力要留給老客戶
因為不夠用
所以前面講說
算力已經什麼夠用
要往下就立刻就被打臉
我們在上集才剛講完說
很快會被打臉
沒有想到打臉這麼快
就是一兩天就打臉
但是要強調一下
就算一下所有的基本面都是on track那甚至是有一點憂鬱預期我覺得跑得蠻不錯但是股價難講我真的難講就是你不知道會不會可能他還是需要去整理或是休息一陣子之後才怎麼樣所以我們就去規劃多重的劇本
像剛剛前面聊到
我會規劃說一個
假設是區間盤的劇本是怎麼樣
那假設是衝起來的劇本是怎麼樣
然後去找好可能相對應
我想要去涉略的標的
然後對照一下中小跟大型股
到底是哪一個牆
然後選擇就把錢往那個方向開
就是還是會有這樣的一些規劃
這個東西其實它不完全是跟基本面子有關
因為簡單來講就像上集QA有一個聽眾問的
他說為什麼它的股票不會漲
我就想跟他講說
幹 下一堆東西我都覺得該漲
可是它不會漲
他怎麼可以修正修的這麼深
你也覺得莫名其妙
其實那個成績都很好
所以對 現在市場就是大家都覺得自己被冤枉
到底最後面市場之神會選哪些東西拉起來
我們沒有辦法下去做預判
我們只能夠看到之後
趕快加入上車
這是自己的規劃
但是我自己覺得我應該不會加的非常的大力
在過去一陣子甚至我開始去把一些那種
還記得我在4月多
在抱怨說券商不給我借錢
可是我過去我想一想
我都要去放假了
我的媽還扛著一些那種借錢的部位
即便整體的槓桿比超低
基本上是沒有
還是會覺得這樣子我就會一直看盤
我不想一直看盤
所以就會打得相對的保守一點
但是我們還是會持續的去關注一些題材
然後希望大家可以在裡面打獵順利
大概是這樣
接下來我們進去Q的部分
第一位肚子好飽
嗨夢宮Chika
關於股價可以分為EPS乘以4P
一旦發現各家機構寫出的報告
PE倍數都是莫名其妙給一個倍數
可以理解機構是為了工作出報告
主要重心會放在故事的撰寫
跟EPS盡量估得準
可是實際在打股票
Forward PE 夢工你具體會怎麼使用呢
給上下緣的倍數
單純看自己相不相信那個故事嗎
還是通常你會怎麼用 愛您
然後講一些關鍵字
就是你到底buy不buy in
這個故事是非常重要的
所以對我們來講
看報告的一個關鍵是
首先我要先知道說
大家的模型是怎麼樣估
再來是我要知道目前大家的預期是到怎麼樣
就來說過往一個我們知道它交易區間
是在forward的可能15到30倍的東西
可是現在報告每個人都給40倍
你就要去注意你有沒有可能是最後一隻老鼠
當然可能魚尾會超級大跟黃帶魚一樣
這是有機會我們也看過好幾次
當然就是要比較小心一點
像這種我們就一定會搭配技術面的停損跟停力點
因為如果說實際不對的話
那我們一定要跑第一個
沒有辦法跑到可能最領先
也不要跑最後一個啦
不要說什麼鎖跌梯被關在裡面之類
所以我們會去參考一點點
這樣的估值的指標
但那確實是不太重要
因為其實你會注意到
絕大多數當他們在瘋狂上修目標
就是一個股價已經在飆了
然後大家在比誰可以喊得更高
過去甚至有一些法人單位
他最著名的就是他們會喊出那種
恨年高目標價
然後因為人都不會到
可是他就知道怎麼樣
他要獲得一些關注
事實上真的是這樣子
就是一個報告要有話題
要有人看 要有人討論
要有一些客戶會喜歡或什麼的
他需要一些你知道
就是一些可能比較聳動的東西
所以我們不會太在意這個東西
但是會參考
會去看一下大概是怎麼樣估
你講到的才是關鍵
就是到底這個故事我相信不相信
然後再來更棒的什麼
更棒的是我知道的一些訊息
可是我看了這些報告
我發現你們沒有人有寫到
這個就代表說你有alpha
就這個東西有可能後面
就會造成一些意外的上修
等到大家發現之後
可能少估了兩塊錢
這兩塊錢再加上它的倍數
那個就是你純純的獲利
所以其實我們會去看說
第一個這個故事我相不相信
再來就是有沒有是你不知道
但是我知道的東西
這個對我們來講
可能是以現階段來說
比較重要的東西
下面一位
來去蔡希
吃水果豆花GI酒
夢宮大午安在晚上七八點提供一個戰場
真的太會吸流量了
想跟昨天吃水西瓜的兄弟說一聲
不吃沙的不如不要吃
都是兄弟開玩笑的
不論你吃沙還是吃水的
明天7月23號準時開完紅眼入比
非常感謝這個來去菜市場假水果豆花兄弟
非常感謝你的支持
對我自己本身在西瓜是站在沙沙派這裡
為什麼昨天突然間在我的線動發一系列的
問大家意見的東西是因為
我自己本身喜歡吃沙沙的西瓜
所以像有一次我老婆買一個西瓜
我說媽怎麼這麼難吃
他說這個是他已經是買到
就是相對比較貴的西瓜了
我說這個超難吃
我小時候吃的都是沙沙的
所以後來我自己的妹妹
聽到這件事情之後
她就在回來路上
就幫我買那種沙沙的西瓜
可是她買沙沙西瓜的時候
老闆竟然跟她講一個
我覺得幹超怪的話
老闆就說你知道那個沙沙西瓜
就是已經是熟透
準備要壞掉的
所以一般可能沒有人要買這個吧
你怎麼會想要買莎莎的西瓜
所以我妹也覺得很納悶
因為我們從小都吃莎莎的西瓜
所以我才想問說
到底是莎莎西瓜好還是水水的西瓜好
因為像我老婆她是喜歡水水的西瓜
最後面我們甚至得出一個小結論
因為我媽媽從小是一個比較那種精打細算的
就是很厲害的那種大媽
她去買菜會有辦法抓到
哪個東西便宜
然後就會大量少或者之類
所以我妹就給我們一個比較大膽的猜測
就會不會莎莎西瓜是比較便宜的東西因為按照我媽採購的邏輯是這樣嗎所以我們從小吃習慣了所以它是我們童年的味道我們才喜歡因為像可能在當天一起吃西瓜的一些人他們表示他們從小都是吃水水的西瓜
所以那可能是一個味道建立的差異
所以就想說來問看看大家的意見
然後後來我記得好像沙沙西瓜比較多一點吧
其他東西的話就比較沒有爭議
就覺得說薯條大家都喜歡吃脆脆的
沒有人喜歡吃軟的
那種少部分反社會也喜歡吃軟的
水蜜桃大家喜歡吃軟的
沒有人要吃硬的
除了少部分反社會的
還敢蜜我跟我說什麼
水蜜桃一定要吃硬的
一個人罵怪咖
怪咖妹妹
反正總之就是
絕大多數的東西
大家都蠻有共識的
可是大家的共識是不一的
所以我現在很喜歡吃沙的
現在吃水
我喜歡吃沙的
下面一位
蘭陽地區快樂寶貝一號
夢宮期間安安
聽到您說陪小孩那一段超有感
深刻感受小孩長大很多一起的時間
過去就沒了
像是四歲的兒子上禮拜跟我說
你說錯了要說晚
不能夠說晚彎
因為我已經長大了
你不要再用两个字了
另外听梦公说快乐宝贝都觉得好笑
但听老公说你是快乐宝贝妈
我却一秒暴怒
吵架的时候说老婆快乐宝贝
是不是缺乏求生欲的表现
最后借梦公金口祝推我听鼓癌的
我们家老公可以顺利把自己开心的工作
转换成为可以赚钱的工作
我们三个都很爱你
也祝梦公一家平平安安健健康康
适合在最适合的时间点喜获女儿
非常感谢
不是啊
你的最後一段
我怎麼覺得有一點
passive aggressive的感覺
就是你現在一直在臭你老公說
他喜歡做我的工作
不太會賺錢
所以希望說
這個工作趕快去賺錢
還是說老公正在經營某一些
他非常有理念的東西
然後他也不知道這個東西可不可以賺錢
那我們希望可以賺錢
我希望是後者
而不是前者
就是你媽要偷臭他
他叫你快樂寶貝
然後去臭他
對 我們希望老公可以順利
然後再講說這個孩子感觸的
對 後面有蠻多地方家長浮出來
然後大家都有類似的感受
其實很多時候當我知道說我的一些想法
因為平常我沒有太多人可以交流
在節目上跟大家交流
然後大家有一樣的一些意見
那個感覺真的是非常好
希望我們都可以好好的把握時間
下面一位
紅班長孟公你好
家父近期第四次遇到網路交友詐騙
對不起
不該笑
無論家人怎麼勸貼再多的真實案例給他看
他依然執意匯款
深信對方會來見面
我們其實已經無奈到想放棄
但最怕的是
我問他如果錢全部被騙光怎麼辦
他竟然說自我了斷
面對這種講不聽錢快被騙光還用生命威脅的舉家人真的很無助想問這題該怎麼解這題我覺得一定是要去找專業人士的幫忙可能就是要去找地方的里長一起下來聊天
找個什麼警察
雖然警察已經很忙了
但我覺得拜託一下
然後再來就是可能找一些心理輔導單位
都要一起來問一下
這個已經是有點偏差跑掉了
但是不知道什麼
某個程度上我可以大概理解它
如果說我今天去走到某個階段是
我隨便亂舉例
我太太也掛掉了或什麼的
我也沒事做又不知道幹嘛
我還真的可能就想說
好啊這個詐騙的來
搞不好真的有一個是真愛啊
好玩啊
我跟你講話的過程之中
多巴胺分泌啊
我覺得很爽啊
然後給你騙點錢
我覺得也沒差
錢被騙光你問我要怎麼樣
那就乾脆去跳一跳啊
反正我也不知道要幹嘛
有機會會講出這樣子的話
可是一般會講出這樣的話
當時的心理狀態應該已經是一個
就是準備要tip over了吧
他有可能是
第一個他本來的狀態就已經不太好
所以他有一種那種
死了就算人的心情
這個我可以理解
因為以前我也會
有時候會有這樣的心情
第二個是他可能已經是被騙太多次
騙到自己都覺得沒面子了
所以他就講他投鐵我不信
我就試給你看我可以試出來
這個我們在一些長輩
或是一些我們客家要講
東安鞠 硬警的人
那種反正就是說
名字是山有虎 偏王虎三行
直到可能被咬掉一條腿
他都還在想說
靠北這個老虎可能只要跟我玩
就是有些人他真的是這樣子
像這樣子的人的話
我覺得是要去找專業的治療
因為這個像我自己
我覺得我蠻會幫人家出點子
我看過很多事情的人
我都告訴你說
這個應該是無解
這應該是沒有辦法解
我們也是丟給專業人士
我們也不知道專業人士有沒有辦法解
如果說沒有辦法解的話
至少你曾經嘗試過
因為這已經有點那種suicidal的一個心態了
他就是捨算了
他就覺得說反正人生是遊戲一場
這種真的很難解
東郎娘 郎娘娘的原因 講不通 沒Q
下面一位
J.Cole Chan 夢宮是我啦
為夢想而窒息的男人
明天7月23號做我美麗的空姐老婆Elaine的生日
想請你幫我告訴她生日快樂
親愛的老婆不要再年齡焦慮了
你永遠是我心中最美麗高貴的存在
尤其是每當我獲利回吐到
軟蛋快捏破的時候
我都會想起輸了錢又如何
最珍貴的資產永遠是我老婆
呃
快吐了
永遠愛你
如果說非要在這份愛上加一段話
我希望是
不要在宵夜都老公煮
不要碗筷都老公在洗
不要在老公每天快了兩小時
打low的時光中瘋狂中斷我
一下叫我撿狗大便
一下叫我做家事
一下裸體在那邊晃來晃去干擾我
最後不要整天不爽就在打老公
你不是才答應我
不會打我了嗎
不准打我當紓壓
雖然靠北一堆
但他依舊是我最愛的好老婆
生日快樂白的味道到底誰西瓜在吃沙的那你牛排怎麼不吃柴的你看我後來發現說這可能是小時候口味建立的一個問題因為像我太太他們就是吃雞胸肉
應該說很多歐洲地方的人
你都知道他們是吃雞胸肉
他們不喜歡吃雞腿
可是我喜歡吃雞腿
可是像我爸他喜歡吃雞胸肉
那他的理由是什麼
他的理由是以前我老公老婆
就給他吃雞胸肉
所以他從小就覺得雞胸肉
才是雞該有的一個口感
類似這樣子
所以我們不知道沙跟水到底怎麼樣
但他很有爭議
我覺得其實有爭議是好的
代表你種出來的兩種西瓜
活生之士因為保存而產生的問題
像莎莎的西瓜
你知道怎麼樣嗎
莎莎西瓜如果說
他被有去泡在西瓜水裡面泡在酒的話
他其實會變水水的
這時候怎麼樣
這時候拿去給那些喜歡水水的吃
前面非常恭喜你們一個很好的關係
前面講的時候我還在那邊
好噁喔
在那邊給我曬很矮
但後面馬上就是個咄吐
其中一個我真的也要在這邊呼籲一下
各位地方老婆
就是打Low的時候不要去中斷老公
拜託這個打Low的時間就很珍貴了
就不多了
然後再來是怎麼樣
你感覺你是消耗一個人的時間
不死
你是消耗九個人的時間
因為你老公在那邊雷
在那邊AFK
剩下的九個人對面也沒意思
你那四個隊友打了也打不贏
所以就會變成
對就是讓大家變成是浪費時間
所以千萬不要在老公打電動的時候
去中斷人家
我覺得這個是
希望各位地方太太都可以做到
你們每次都講說什麼
我小虎然後去幫忙你們管老公
但這個
我跟你講你真的不要做這種
沒有品德的事情
老公在打電動的時候不要煩他
有什麼事情導完電動再講
一場時間沒有多久
下面一位
嚴格上來說是這樣子
2327它現在還原回去
還是是一個2000多塊
快3000多塊的股票
在最高點的時候
甚至是4000多塊的一個股票
所以其實當年套在1000多塊的人
全部都解套跟賺錢
就是我覺得當然
市場上有些人會不喜歡說
有些公司你不是簡直退大家錢
就是說你不需要這麼多錢
然後你後來又在增資或什麼
你就是想把人家稀釋掉
把人家洗掉
這個其實很多公司
都在做類似的事情
只是我們在這邊不好點名
因為我們節目的受眾太多了
我也不想去惹到任何人
反正大家去查歷史
你問AI一定都可以告訴你
那種簡直在增資把人家洗掉的
或者說什麼先下市再上市的
很多啦
那該怎麼樣去評斷
我老實說年輕的時候
我都覺得這些人在割韭菜
可是長大一點就會懂
像某記憶體廠
他們為什麼那時候會這樣做
或是某晶圓代工廠
為什麼我那時候會這樣做
其實都有理由
因為當下可能不這樣做
他也沒有太多的選項了
所以他就是會傷害到一些既有的股東
然後等他真的變好之後
也不是當時賠他的那些股東可以賺到
所以在資本市場
我覺得至少他比起
我們去做一些初級市場的投資
他的好處是在於說
你發現這個公司有問題
就像說你覺得他是無良的公司
你就不要買他
市場的選擇這麼多
你幹嘛要去買了他之後
然後又再去幹掉他
或甚至是你可以更壞一點
你知道他每次都用同一個pattern去割韭菜
我就問你你為什麼不要在
你知道他要割韭菜的時候
你在那邊把他空爆之類的
所以我覺得自己市場有趣的地方是
其實你不爽都可以不要做
或是你可以跟他對坐什麼的
所以我們就不用去問太多為什麼
因為每家公司可能都有他一貫的做法
像我有時候對一些公司也有意見
你為什麼要配那麼多股息
我超級討厭股息的
因為對我來講每個都要繳稅
可是台灣的一些中小股民
他們超愛股息的
因為他們某個程度上都覺得說
這個只手是配到我口袋裡面
然後他們沒有去摸到
可能28%分離課稅這種
所以他沒差
他媽你配股息給我
我就覺得高股息讚
所以你看意見不一樣
我喜歡他不喜歡
對於某些人來講
其實我甚至這樣說
一些在發CB
一些在搞現真的公司
這個你如果去論壇問
大家也說割韭菜
他這個就是拉高
然後什麼就要去搞現證
可是對某些人來講
我們喜歡去買這樣子的標的
因為我知道公司要
好股票
我知道公司要搞
我知道你要這樣做
所以我們看得懂的
我們就會上車
所以你都可以去做自己的選擇
就不會覺得說
這個是風險或什麼的
因為其實簡單來講就是
你只要懂看的
你就會知道
你說那些不知道的
莫名其妙被割到的
那就只能夠說比較遺憾一點
當然會希望說有關單位
看可不可以多一點警示的東西
但這就跟那個詐騙一樣
就是你如果真的做太多限制的話
你反而是讓正常人的生活
是沒有辦法做
只能夠說你本來要去做股票
你就應該都要去了解這些東西
你不了解的東西
你怎麼會敢賣對吧
然後下面一位
大綱夢公安
想請問如果說爸媽家裡衣服很多
大概1000件那種
想要幫他們處理
但他們又會說
每件衣服都有感情的該怎麼辦
目前才按兵不動的策略
是不是要等到屬於他們的直男巧虎出現
靠著命運的第三方力量
才可以讓他們開始斷舍離
但老媽的直男巧虎是GDLOL
來自因為夢宮而執行
坐尿派許久的林口地方聽眾
其實蠻多人的爸媽都有屯屋
像我自己的爸媽在認識我老婆之前
也算是某個程度上的屯屋屋
我爸爸是有潔癖的
就是我爸爸他會把東西都打掃得很乾淨
可是他有很多東西他就會覺得說
以後可能會用到
捨不得丟或者說怎麼樣的所以他厲害在他至少知道每個東西都在哪結果你知道我老婆才剛到我們家可能頭幾次見面吧他就受不了就開始在我家丟東西然後一開始以前是這樣就是假設我們跟爸爸說要把一些東西丟掉
或是你自己亂丟一些東西
他會把你那麽臭幹
他真的就是臭幹你一頓
可是我老婆丟他就可能也不好意思吧
他就沒有臭幹老婆
他就是一臉那種很尷尬的尬笑
然後有時候會怎麼樣
他會在晚上的時候偷偷的去外面
然後把那些東西撿回來
我老婆就是再把他丟掉
所以我老婆也是那種他就ganster你知道嗎
他沒有在插小的
他就是丟
然後去那冰箱
把冰箱的東西全部拿出來丟
丟一丟丟到後來
還真的就是家庭的節奏就改變了
所以不知道
你去娶個養媳婦吧
還是怎麼樣的
因為就是要那種去顛覆他們傳統
他們又罵不下去
因為如果一樣是台灣人
他可能就會覺得說他可以罵你
因為當時我家人是這樣被改變
反正就是丟一丟之後
後來他們就懂了
後來是這樣
後來像我幫家裡添購一個新的冰箱
那時候就是跟我太太聊到說
以前我們家裡的冰箱
有那種過期16年的番茄醬
超屌
然後再來就是
你知道以前我們是怎麼樣用冷凍庫嗎
就覺得所有東西丟到冷凍庫就是無敵了
它就是不會壞掉
所以冷凍庫一堆那種塑膠袋包著的東西
那天就是剛好講到這件事情
跟一個地方朋友
我就說我們家冰箱是這樣子
然後我老婆說
沒有你知道你把他媽媽
你幫他換新的冰箱之後
他們就很小心的在收納
他們冰箱超乾淨的
我看到都嚇到
所以這也是一個可能性
我把兩個契機給你
一個是我老婆在那邊丟東西
然後丟到我爸爸被迫習慣
然後另外一個是
來幫他們換一些新的設備
或是你假設幫他改一些裝潢
說不定他會想要維持新的設備的乾淨跟整理
他們就會去做這樣子處理
這兩個小緊囊
希望對你有幫助
下面一位
Jack Chung
是不是練過
念一下
MK5R最近的盤勢動盪
所以前新研究中
雖然過程不簡單
有問題也沒有辦法一次就修正好
例如邏輯不順暢
表達不完整
沒有問出好的問題
輸出太過口語化之類的
當然還是可以確定自己
每次都會被打磨
變累積一點
這也很令人開心
像是練等一樣
因為沒有什麼想問的
就麻煩MK無情工商紅眼露比一波
讓像小弟這樣子
沒有玩過太多遊戲的小白
也能夠知道怎麼體驗吧
祝您全家平安健康
天天開心愛您
不知道什麼我覺得超感動的
就是一個我認為是很重要的事情
然後蠻多聽眾
也把它當priority
他們留言會提到
我希望大家都身體健康
希望你們的股票都發大財
非常感謝這麼多暖男
對 希望大家都去玩這個紅眼露比
那不知道怎麼玩的呢
你去下載一個平台叫做steam
S-T-E-A-M
因為確實有些人他可能是完全不打遊戲的
反正網路有一個App叫Steam
你下載下來之後
我們把它稱為是男生的百貨公司雖然有些人可能也是男生但你沒有打電動 你不是宅男人不知道但你只要下載這個男生的百貨公司之後你就會變得跟我們身邊的一些女伴一樣就是你會定期的想要上去逛某些東西
你會買一些東西回家
接著你可能一輩子都不會打開它
但是你會很驕傲的告訴大家
你收藏了什麼東西
像是可能你太太那種架上的香奈兒包
你就說你看我有全系列的
可能 Witcher的遊戲還是什麼的
其中我兩三款沒有玩過
就爽我就放在那邊
以後的孩子可以玩
也不一定啦
因為現在蠻多人會買一堆H-GAME
可能又不敢跟孩子分享
他可能他死前的最後一個願望是
除了這個D槽清掉之外
我的Steam帳號要幫我銷毀掉
因為裡面有太多有的沒有的遊戲
有可能是這樣
但他承載了很多人的回憶
那他也是很多人找到快樂的泉源
反正你抓到這個Steam之後
你就可以
他就會像是一個百貨公司一樣
然後很多的遊戲
然後在夏天在冬天都會有一些特價
就很棒
就讓大家很有那種參與感
你可以在上面就去找紅眼露比
然後跟暗花夜站
暗就是晚上的暗
花花flower
夜晚
那讚綻放
這個也是我們的遊戲
我們參與投資的遊戲
就先把它稱為是我們的遊戲
這個下有demo可以玩
那黃銀露比目前也是有demo
但明天正式上市
你就可以拿出你的魔法小卡
刷下去
就算你可能不會玩遊戲
你也可以讓你的兒子玩
或是讓你的朋友玩
希望大家都可以支持
優質的台灣遊戲開發團隊
下面一位
Restling Chan
夢攻Chika安
發現打Chika的時候會自動選字
選成China
China
7月10號是我女朋友的生日
麻煩幫我跟括號是藍的女朋友說
那四個字生日快樂
你看終於老實了
想請問你在心露谷物語的女角排名
括號SVE也可以
我每次都在Haley跟Abigail之間猶豫
祝夢公去把全家開心
諾亞安哥平平安安長大
這個人的性癖跟我一樣
這樣講性癖好像不太對
偏好
我也是覺得Haley跟Abigail蠻不錯的
我沒有記錯的話
你可以去像是那個什麼
Nexus mode
然后可以找到新入股的MODE
你可以把它们改得更性感的模样
这个给你参考看看
下面一位还在想ID
孟公安第一次留言
从以前就会有赔钱股票
不想认赔的坏习惯
前阵子稍微的改掉
但最近这种盘又觉得
好像傲一下会回来
该怎么改掉这个坏习惯呢
那另外想跟高雄金宇斌说
虽然股市路上起起伏伏
看到别人跟单转烂
会怀疑自己是不是研究方向错误
但希望可以靠自己赚大钱一起加油
也祝孟公全家身体健健康康
開開心心愛你
我愛你
這題我覺得不好回答
理論上像我們都知道說這個股票要有一定程度的紀律如果說你設定的的條件達成了那你就應該要出場那它可能是某一條均線或者說某一次的財報的結果或什麼的
如果說達成理論上對
你就要比較硬性的出場
但是我必須得說在過去的幾年
我也變得我不喜歡太硬性的停損
我覺得我有這樣子的改變是
我對我自己的研究實力
或是掌握度有更深的體會
我發現說其實我東西幾乎都會看對
所以除非是我知道
有更好的機會成本的地方
就是我換去那邊
那個東西一看就是馬上要噴的
我才會換過去
不然有時候就算它可能已經達到
過往我會要出場的地方
就在說它摸到月線了
那我就沒有出去
因為以前我可能這個月線我就會出去
可是現在就會覺得說
也懶得動了
反正就給它洗一洗
搞不好後面就再上去或什麼的
因為你已經有一些經驗
可以去支持你這樣做
所以我會覺得
當然你現在沒有經驗的時候
你確實是要有一些比較硬性的
防呆機制
就類似說以前那個3.5磁片
不是反過來就推不進去嗎
或者光碟片如果你放反
那就沒有辦法讀取
你要有一些這樣的機制去預防
你上頭了你知道
你被鬼牽走
或是說你暈車之類的
然後你可能會死在裡面
你要設計這樣的一個機制
但是你後來開始稍微懂之後
我覺得我們都是用一個
部位商先去做封控而已
就比較不會像過去
去設一些那種很硬性的聽力的點
像這次老實講
那種中小在大回檔的時候
其實我也是因為說成本拉太遠
所以我前面也膨脹
因為以前就是
你知道這種東西都已經噴出去
都已經處置這麼多天了
以前怎麼樣 時日線我可能就丟
再不計月線丟
就這一波有蠻多是
我快到計線我才丟
為什麼 因為你就覺得說
反正我賺這麼多
但後來真的回到計線
你也覺得蠻痛的
等於你少賺超大一段
但就是這樣吧
我覺得那個東西都有彈性
就來說如果今天這個東西
它並沒有噴這麼兇的話
我一定是守得很嚴
就是因為你想說噴多了
那過往其實台股的慣性
在過去的半年一年就是
拉回隨便買都會贏
想說這次可能也一樣
但這次就真的不一樣
就回比較深一點
所以該怎麼做還是有去做處理
只是比过往慢
所以我觉得那会有一定程度的弹性存在
但如果你是新手的话
尽量不要有太多的弹性
下面一位
Rangee
今年五月电脑展有看出跟前两年比较起来
从之前的GPU散热方案
今年大部分摊位多了很多CPU跟800V的机柜方案
比起CPU感觉800V这一块
美股反应的还没有很多
是否可以期待下半年有机会往800V去反应
以及主要在800V有特别看好的美股企业吗
像是Navitas Wolfspeed
然後跟STM
可以 其實可以
但是我覺得
可能比較難去處理
因為我們家可能很習慣
我覺得是因為過去的慣性
就是我知道說可能國際族群
〔此段辨識失敗，約 50:00 起〕